ما كانت امريكا تستخدمه ضد العرب ها هي
اليوم تلقي به صوب روسيا الامريكان
يعلنونها سنستغل الامور ونجعلك تحارب من
اجل مصالحنا
تحت طوعكم فقط كونوا بجانبي الدب الروسي
بصوت عال نفهم كل ما يدور في الخفاء
وستدفعون ثمن الدمار الذي سيحدث ما
هي تتهوى وما هو الثمن الذي حصل عليه
الاخير وكيف حولت امريكا اوكرانيا الى
قفاز ملاكمه يوجه ضرباته صوب روسيا بشكل
مباشر وكيف ردت موسكو على التحدي الامريكي
الذي فجر بركان الغضب في المنطقه لتعرف
اجابه كل تلك الاسئله تابع الفيديو
للنهايه
هديه مرعبه في الايادي الاوكرانيه
ضباع واشنطن ينفخون النار في شرق اوروبا
وربما في العالم كله واشنطن تصدم المجتمع
الدولي معلنه انها ستمد اوكرانيا بالقاتل
الصامت نعم انها الذخائر المميته او
القنابل العنقوديه العالم اصبح على صفيح
ساخن فهذا السلاح محرم دوليا من قبل 123
دوله اي العالم كله تقريبا واليوم واشنطن
تسلمه لاوكرانيا وبمنتهى البساطه في صفقه
مساعدات عسكريه تخطت قيمتها 800 مليون
دولار لا احد يعلم هل سيدفعهم زيلينسكي
فعلا ام انها هديه كبيره مقابله في خدمه
كبرى لوشنطن وهي اشبه بضربه تحت الحزام
لروسيا والهدف طرح الدب الروسي ارضا
واراحه الضبع الامريكي من ازعاجه وقتل كل
مخاوفه ولكن هل سينجح زيلينسكي في
اصداء العمر لبي
دان الكارثه
يبدو ان اعلان واشنطن تزويد كياف بهذا
السلاح لم يكن مجرد استمرار في دعمك بل هو
اعلان عن كارثه كبرى تنتظر المنطقه وقد
تدفع بالحرب الى مسار سيهدم المعبد على
راس الجميع حتى ان المتحدثه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخرفه خرجت قائله
قرار امريكا تزويد كياف بالذخائر
العنقوديه يعتبر دليلا على الضعف بعد فشل
الهجوم المضاد واشنطن تتحمل مسؤوليه اطاله
امد الحرب واستمرار كييف في القتال حتى
اخر اوكراني وكل من سيقتل الان سيكون دمه
في رصيد امريكا بمن فيهم الاطفال الروس
والاوكرانيون لم تهتز واشنطن باتهام موسكو
لياتي الرد من الفينتاجون سريعا وفي تحدي
سنستمر في تعميكي طالما يتطلب الامر ذلك
واشنطن وموسكو ستشعلان الكوكب بينما يبقى
الطرف الوحيد الذي انتابه القلق هو الامم
المتحده التي خرج فرحان حق نائب المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للمنظمه في محاوله
لتهدئه الاوضاع قائلا الامين العام
انطونيو يؤكد على اهميه اتفاقيه حظر
استخدام الذخائر العنقوديه في الحروب
ويشدد على وقف استخدامها من اي طرف في
ساحات المعارك وبرغم كل الانتقادات
الموجهه لامريكا يبقى الامر الاكثر رعبا
هو ان الولايات المتحده نفسها ليست عضوا
في اتفاقيه حظر استخدام الذخائر العنقوديه
اي ان كل هذا قد يظل مجرد صيحات يتبخر
صداها في الهواء
تبرير ام مناوره امريكيه
بعد النقد الدولي لتصرف امريكا خرجت
جيكسيلوفان مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
ليقول نحن مضطرون لتزويد اوكرانيا بهذه
الذخائر لتدافع عن نفسها امام الهجوم
الروسي وقد حصلنا على ضمانات مكتوبه
الملكيه تؤكد فيها انها لن تستخدمها بما
يضر المدنيين كما قمنا بتخفيض نسبه الفشل
في الانفجار بهذه الذخائر الى ما دون
الثلاثه بالمئه الاوكرانيون في اشد الحاجه
لتلك الذخائر خصوصا وان حلفائها من الغرب
يستطيعون تامين ذخائر مدفعيه لكياف تؤدي
في النهايه الى تحقيق النصر او حتى
استعاده الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي تسيطر
عليها روسيا درسنا الامر لوقت طويل وتم
تاجيله لاكثر من مره كان القرار صعبا
ولكننا اتخذناه في النهايه مضطرين ورغم
التبرير الامريكي فلا احد يعلم النوايا
الحقيقيه لوشنطن وراء تزويدك بسلاح خطير
كهذا فالبيت الابيض اعلن انه استشار
حلفاءه قبل اتخاذ هذا القرار ولكن يرى
محللون ان واشنطن لا تستشير احدا بل
تبلغهم ليستعدوا في تحضير ردود دبلوماسيه
يدافعون بها عن انفسهم وان صح هذا فهذا
يعني ان امريكا قد حولت الحرب من حرب
تحرير اوكرانيا الى استخدام اوكرانيا في
حرب بالوكاله تخدم اهداف ابناء العم سام
وتريحهم من طموحات الدب الروسي الذي طالت
مخالبه وجه الضبع الامريكي نفسه ولكن
السؤال الان هل زيلينسكي هو الشخص المناسب
الذي يمكن ان تعتمد عليه واشنطن في تحقيق
هذه المهمه